the breaking news to bring you in the
last few minutes the Prime Minister has
confirmed that he will attend the cop 27
climate Summit in Egypt after all the
prime minister has just written this on
Twitter there is no long-term Prosperity
without action on climate change there
is no energy security without investing
in Renewables that is why I will attend
cop 27 next week to deliver on glasgow's
Legacy of building a secure and
sustainable future well uh joining me
now is our political correspondent
Tamara Cohen tomorrow this is a bit of a
U-turn isn't it
it is Ian we got wind earlier this week
that the Prime Minister was considering
going having been ruled out last Friday
when we were told by number 10 that his
sole Focus was the Autumn statement and
raising people's taxes and cutting
public spending he wanted to put all his
effort into that which is only in two
weeks time we then got wind earlier this
week that he might be going and number
10 said that if he got enough work done
on the Autumn statement before Sunday
when the summit starts in Egypt then he
might make an appearance now confirmed
why has he done this well I think
perhaps number 10 was surprised by the
level of backlash from conservatives I
think many Saw Boris Johnson's hosting
of the last Summit here in Glasgow as a
great success and that the environment
and particularly the amount of energy
generated from Renewables is a record
that the conservatives can shout about
at a time when there frankly isn't very
much else that they can shout about
about their recent records so I think he
was a bit surprised by the backlash
among some conservatives the former
Chancellor very former Chancellor in
fact George Osborne suggested he was
trashing the party's record on the
environment don't know how much it
factored in that Boris Johnson confirmed
to Sky News that he would be going at
the invitation of the Egyptians and
perhaps the prospect of the former prime
minister being on the world stage it was
a bit too much to bear but we now know
that Rishi sunak will be going and of
course a good diplomatic opportunity for
him as well as the likes of Joe Biden
and the leaders of major European
countries are expected to be there